in the lobby of her MZ solutions Lee and
Becky are with us hey guys how are you
doing great
welcome welcome good to have you so
where do you guys live Tucson Arizona
fun and you're here to do your debt-free
scream yes sir
I love it how much of you guys paid off
forty two thousand eight hundred and
eighty three dollars I love it and how
long did that take twenty three months
very cool and your range of income
during that time well we started about
sixty thousand a year and right near the
end it got bumped up to 135 whoa you
doubled your income in two years I'll do
that change jobs okay yeah I became an
independent IT contractor okay Wow good
for you so that's what you do you're an
IT and what do you do Becky I'm office
manager at chick-fil-a oh very cool good
for you guys that's fun so what kind of
debt was the forty three thousand well
it was a about half and half
car loan and the other half credit cards
okay
did you sell any stuff or you just tore
into this thing well we thought the car
oh you dad okay all right and I got rid
of half of it I did okay so what are you
driving now old cars Oh cars from the
paid for cars there you go live like no
one else drive like no one else later
you can live like no one else and drive
like no one else that's good very cool
so what happened twenty three months ago
that changed your direction and made you
decide to get out of debt well most of
my life I'd been working in churches
music ministry and teaching music in
small Christian schools and not really
making much money at all ever you know
how that goes but about six years ago we
moved to Tucson Arizona and I thought
I'd get another ministry position or or
school position I looked for music
teaching couldn't find anything and so I
saw a job for teaching computers and
teaching technology and also being their
network administrator for a couple of
charter schools there was an
organization of two charter schools well
I started working for them and with a
very very low income as I make twenty
twenty eight thousand a year then my
first year six years ago and their
school they
expanded and they needed me to go
full-time network administrator well I
got a pretty good rate did that and I
thought well hey I hit the big time now
and I what first thing I did was go out
and buy a nearly new car not very smart
and about the same time I bought that
car I started listening to you on the
radio as I drove from the schools you
know from just ruins the it just was
rough yeah
and so we just well there's the school
dick they gave me another big race
that's what happened they gave me
another pretty big raises they added a
fourth school to our group and and I
thought wow I'm making more money I'd
ever made before but I realized there's
something wrong why am I still broke why
is it I mean we've been bounced a check
during this time this was crazy hmm
so I've been listening to you and I said
I came home and told Becky said we're
gonna buy this book Total Money Makeover
I'm gonna buy it and we're gonna read it
and so I bought the book and a couple of
days later started reading it she read
it right afterwards we were right on
board from that point on so Becky he
comes home and starts acting all weird
and saying he's gonna buy this book what
did you say well he'd been telling me
stuff that he'd heard you say on the
radio and it always made sense and so I
was like let me read it let me read it
and when it was time to start I was like
let's start right now today today and
he's like wait says first of my personal
month no I like it she goes for it man
that's awesome very cool so you've done
really well congratulations
very proud of you you really took
control of things here you sold off the
car and done six months yeah I'll bet
you didn't give it away
you didn't go desperate and crazy you
just said we're gonna we're gonna do
this the right way and now here you sit
with no payments how's it feel amazing
so when people find out that you got out
of debt and they ask how did you do that
what do you tell them the secret to
getting out of debt is well for me I
think that it was
having a budget and working on it
together because our first part of our
marriage I did the finances and he never
knew what was happening and then it was
so stressful that I said you gonna do
the finances but then I never knew what
was going on mm-hmm
and so now we're working on it together
and we have a common goal and it's just
made a big difference that's huge that's
huge
yeah for me the hardest part was selling
the car yeah yeah because I knew I was
way under what you know underwater with
it
you know but I basically lost about half
the cost of the car when I sold it it
was it was really hard to do that yeah
than that well it's kind of like you
know it's either that or the things
sitting in the driveway every time you
walk towards that it calls you stupid I
mean because that's that's what it does
I want to do stuff like that I don't
want rid of the reminder yeah it's
painful well congratulations you guys
we're very proud of you Chris Hogan's
new book retire inspired number one
bestseller is the next chapter in your
life that's where you build wealth and
you increase your generosity to an
outrageous level and you're right on
track to do that you guys have done a
great great job
all right Leigh and Becky Tucson Arizona
$43,000 paid off in 23 months making 60
now making 135 count it down let's there
a debt free scream three two one
good job you guys awesomeness
awesomeness that's how you do it right
there hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
economy